each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available welcome everybody um it's my
pleasure to introduce um Ashraf abula
who's visiting here from University of
waterl
um I think a lot of people here know
Ashraf for a variety of reasons and um
but he's done a pretty broad range of
work in the database field and the last
few years has kind of moved into new
areas focusing on cloud computing and
and um data integration of of of web
data um and in particular his work on um
on um part of the work he's going to
describe here today on on cloud Compu
Computing was in a vldb paper just a
couple months ago that won best paper
award there um which by the way was
incorrectly listed as vldb 2012 in the
in the advertising that went around it's
you know maybe he'll have one there too
who knows we'll see but um anyway
without further Ado let me turn it over
to ashref thank you
Phil good morning everybody and uh
thanks for coming to my talk so the
title of my talk is uh High availability
for database systems in cloud computing
environments more generally it's about
providing a database service in the
cloud and before I start the technical
material in my talk let me start with
some thanks that are due this is Joint
work with my colleague Professor k salum
at the University of watero and the
first part of the work is the work of my
PhD student Omar minhas who was an
intern at Microsoft research uh a couple
of times before and he is graduating
next year and needs a job so if you guys
have jobs to
offer Omar's your guy uh the second part
of the talk is the work of Ru U who was
a postdoc jointly supervised by Ken and
me and he's also finishing in 2012 and
also needs a
job uh and the first part of the talk is
collaboration with people univers of
Rich Columbia Professor Andrew Warfield
and his graduate
students so as I said this talk is about
or my interest in this area is about uh
using Cloud Technologies plus SQL
database systems to build a scalable
highly available database service in the
cloud and another interest I have in
this area of cloud computing is what if
I don't care about a scalable highly
available database service what if I
have my own instance of a database
system and I want to deploy it in the
cloud I want to run it on a virtual
machine how can we improve the way uh
database systems interact with these
virtual machines and also how can we
improve the underlying Cloud technology
can we add apis can we add new features
to the uh Cloud Technologies to better
support database
systems so why database systems I mean
why am I focusing on this class of
application well they're important
databases are important and looking at
the people in the crowd I guess we all
agree on that this is not something I
have to spend too much time convincing
you guys of uh but the the question is
why do I think that we can solve this
problem why do I think that focusing on
database systems can get us somewhere
one reason is that database systems have
a narrow interface to the user they
speak SQL so when I when I when we need
to reason about database system we don't
need to reason about General programs in
a language like Java or C we need to
reason about SQL and secondly database
systems have transactions that offer
very well- define semantics for
consistency and
durability uh and thirdly
database systems have these very well-
defined structures very well- defined uh
operators so regardless of your database
system you can always count on it having
a buffer pool you can always count on it
executing queries as uh trees of
operators like hash join uh sort merge
join and so on and finally database
systems are very introspective they have
accurate performance models of their
query execution cost they have accurate
performance models that tell you what
the marginal benefit of uh some extra
memory will be and if you can expose
these models to the underlying Cloud
technology we might get some benefit
from there so for all of these reasons I
think it's promising to look at database
systems as a specific class of
applications and tune specifically for
them and in this talk you'll see that I
Rely heavily on these two aspects I Rely
heavily on the the semantics of
transactions to decide when things have
to be consistent and when they don't
need to be consistent and also rely
heavily on the fact that we have these
well- defined structures and present
optimizations that are tuned towards
things like a buffer pool so in my talk
I'll talk about two projects the first
is Rems DB which is this vldb paper that
uh Phil was talking about and vsdb aims
to provide database High availability
using
virtualization the second part of the
talk I'll talk about a new project
called debex which also aims to provide
database High availability but also
scalability and elasticity by rying on
eventually consistent cloud storage so
let's start with Remus DB and high
availability using
virtualization so first of all what do
we mean by high availability in this
context what we mean is resilience to
Hardware
failure I know that when people talk
about high availability they talk about
scheduled downtime and unscheduled diet
time here we're focused more on the
unscheduled di downtime we're talk
focused on resilience to Hardware
failure and high availability is
becoming an important important
requirement for all kinds of
applications it's not a high-end
Enterprise Mission critical applications
that have to be highly available these
days everything has to be highly
available every Facebook game has to be
highly available nobody expects anything
nobody is willing to accept anything
less than 24/7 up uh up
time and when we talk about high
availability we have to talk talk about
several issues so in the context of
databases we need to maintain database
consistency in the face of failure we
need to minimize the impact on per
performance of the high availability
solution both during normal operation
and also during failover and finally we
have to reduce the complexity and
administrative overhead of high
availability Now High availability has
been around for a while there are many
high availability Solutions out there
and one common way to do high
availability is to do active standby
replication so in this uh when you when
you do active standard application you
run two copies of your database one on a
primary server and one on a backup
server and the primary is the active
server it accepts uh user request and
performs queries the backup is a standby
server and the primary
ships uh changes to the database from uh
to the backup by propagating the
transaction log and the backup is busy
is busy applying these changes so that
when the primary fails the backup can
take over as the primary and it takes
over with a consistent database
state so if if Solutions like this exist
why are we still working in this area
we're still working in this area because
active standby replication is complex to
implement in the database system and
also complex to administer you need to
worry about things like how to propagate
the transaction log in a transactionally
consistent way you need to worry about
the atomicity of of Handover from
primary to backup you need to worry
about redirecting client requests when
the primary fails the backup takes over
as primary the database is consistent
but you need to tell the clients that
now instead of talking to this guy they
need to talk to this guy
and you need to minimize the impact on
performance so for example when the
failover happens you want the failover
to happen to a backup with a warmed up
buffer
pool so it is these Solutions are
complex and what we're aiming to do in
this work is to push this complexity out
of the database system and into the
virtualization
layer and uh you know if I want to
invent a buzzword for this I'd call it
high availability as a service in which
we can make any database system uh
highly available by running it in our
souped up virtual
machine and uh we want to do this with
as little performance overhead as
possible so the idea is still to use
active standby replication we still have
a primary server and a backup server but
now the primary server is running a
virtual machine and the database system
is inside the virtual
machine and the changes we we still
propagate changes from the primary to
the backup but we don't just propagate
changes in the in the database State we
propagate changes in the entire virtual
machine state which includes buffer pool
which includes uh client connection
state so that
uh the when the primary fails the backup
can take over as primary but now it
takes over with a warmed up buffer pool
and clients get failed over
automatically to the backup and this all
happens with no code changes to the
database system
yes so there's a performance penalty in
running a database yes and that should
be less than the performance penalty you
get by the warm cold otherwise there is
a performance penalty for running a
datab bases in the virtual machine but
we didn't really uh study that penalty
in the in this work we assume that you
are willing to run your database system
in a virtual
machine uh and you know there are people
working on red like this is a continuous
process of there is a continuous process
of reducing the penalty of running uh
databas system in virtual machine but
this is part of the equation it is not
part of the equation we focus on in this
work what we focus on is making this
virtual machine highly
available yes so question on the client
fil over how do you implement the
automatic fil over of the client so we
we'll talk about that next okay so Remis
DB is built on Remis which is a a
project that was developed at the vir I
and is now part of the Zen
hypervisor and
Remis does this picture it it it
maintains two copies of virtual machine
one on a primary server on a backup
server and it periodically replicates
the state changes from the primary uh
virtual machine to the backup virtual
machine using whole machine
checkpointing and this whole machine
checkpointing extends live virtual
machine migration so things like uh
failing over the clients from the
primary to the backup are handled by
live VM
migration
okay and the the transparency of fail
over is handled by live virtu VM
migration so remas offers uh transparent
forover with only seconds of downtime so
we had a question yeah you were talking
about is bu be warmed what do you mean
by being is it all the pages in this
cach and also in that cach that in our
case this is what we will achieve the
two virtual machines will be exact
replicas of each
other and that goes just for buff or go
for all the the whole virtual machine
State
okay so how does Remus do this whole
machine checkpoint how does remas
achieve High availability so remas
divides time into
APO uh the APO CL is a tunable parameter
but think of it as 25 milliseconds so
remas lets the primary run uninterrupted
for 25 milliseconds there's there is no
lock step execution between param and
backup here uh and at the end of this
Epoch Remus performs a checkpoint in
which it suspends the primary virtual
machine copies State changes from the
primary virtual machine to domain zero
and for those of you who are not
familiar with Zen terminology domain
zero is a privileged virtual machine
that exists on any uh physical machine
running Zen and it manages it does it's
it's the administrative domain it's
administrative virtual machine so you
copy the state changes to domain zero
and after this copy is done the primary
vertu machine can be
resumed and then asynchronously Dom zero
copies the checkpoint to the backup
server where the backup server applies
it to its
state so here's an example of Remis
checkpointing this is an example showing
three AO a b and c and at the end of
every aoch the there is a checkpoint
that's taken in this examp example the
primary machine fails during epoxy so
when the primary machine fails the
backup takes over and it resumes
executing execution from the latest
checkpoint so work that the primary did
in uh epoxy is lost and it's okay to
lose this work as long as you don't
expose output to the user because you
don't want to expose unsafe
output so the way remas handles that is
that it buffers any output that is
exposed to the user until the end of an
Epoch so let's focus for example on
network packets whenever the machine
that's protected by Remis wants to send
a network packet that Network packet is
buffered until the checkpoint uh at the
end of the APO happens and this the
state becomes safe at that point it's
the packet is released to its
user every
every
on average 12 half milliseconds yes yes
exactly and that's actually part of the
reason we we looked at remas because
remas is there you can run a database
system inside remas but then if you look
at what remas does database workloads
without Remis protection you have a
database client and you have a database
server and the client sends the query to
the server the query process the Ser the
the server process the query and returns
a response that is unprotected and you
got have some response time now if you
enable Remis protection taking
checkpoints adds a certain overhead and
network buffering adds even more
overhead so you end up with uh a
protected uh server but you get a much
bigger response time and the overhead of
protection we measured it to be up to
32% in some cases so our goal in this
work is to implement optimizations that
are database inspired to reduce this
overhead and in the end we're able to
achieve less than 3% overhead and
Recovery within 3
seconds so what I want to talk about now
is the optimizations we do for
Remis s once we take a che do you wait
until the backup applies then before
proceeding you wait until the backup
acknowledges the receipt of the
checkpoint so as long as the checkpoint
is here you can
proceed yes um if you don't wait until
the backup been applied to the secondary
then um there's a possibility that if
both machines go down you lose state
right yes so here we're tolerating one
filling
okay is it extensible to more it in
theory it is but this is not something
that either we or the original authors
of must have have actually explored
it so let me talk about the
optimizations that we Implement so when
we look at Remis and why it's slow for
database workloads we see that it's slow
for two reasons one is that database
systems are heavy users of
memory so we implemented some
optimizations that reduce the overhead
of checkpointing virtual machines where
the memory is being heavily used and we
uh I'm going to talk about two
checkpoints asynchronous checkpoint uh
two optimizations asynchronous
checkpoint compression and discreete
tracking asynchronous checkpoint
compression aims at sending less data
during checkpoints and this R tracking
aims at protecting less
memory another reason why remas is slow
for database workloads is this 12 and a
half millisecond delay that's added to
every Network packet some database
workloads in particular transactional
workload where there's a lot of back and
forth between the client and the server
are very sensitive to this network
latency so the the last optimization we
implemented for Remis is to exploit the
semantics of database trans transactions
to avoid this overhead when we
can so let me talk about the memory
optimizations first so if you look at if
you look at uh the way uh database
systems use memory you'll see that
there's there are large sets of
frequently changing pages of memory one
prime example of that is the buffer pool
but you can also think of the memory
where the connection state with the
clients is stored and if you look at the
way the database system uses its memory
in many cases it's modifying a small
portion of the page so if you look at
the buffer pool in particular you're
seeing that you see that the uh database
system will often write a few will often
modify a few uh Records on the buffer
pool in a buffer pool
page
so there is uh lot of memory that's
being checkpointed there is which
results in a lot of replication traffic
between the primary and the back backup
and there is redundancy in this uh
replic in this replication traffic
because you're modifying the same buff
pool pages over and over again and every
time there's a modification in a small
part of this
page so when you looked at this we said
well instead of sending these redundant
pages over and over again send the
Deltas in the pages and send them
compressed and the way we Implement that
is that we maintain a cache
in domain zero that contains the most
recently seen dirty Pages we get from
the protected virtual machine so as part
of checkpointing the protected virtual
machine sends the dirty pages to domain
zero and domain zero looks in the cache
if these pages are found in the cache
then it does a delta between the
original page and this page compresses
the Deltas and sends them over to the
backup
compressed if the page is not found in
the cache it's sent uh as a whole not
not the Delta and this cache is
maintained as an lru cache so the most
recent pages are stuck in the cash and
the least recently used pages are kicked
out RI what the overhead of this you
said u i you're running this every 25
milliseconds right yes so you you going
to keep a cach for all pages do the
Delta and run so what we do is we in in
our implementation we took 10% of the
memory that's available for Dom zero and
devoted this
cash what is the overhead of running the
Del it should be a very small fraction
of 25 M otherwise it it is yes and and
one important thing to note about this
Delta is about this compression is that
this compression is done asynchronously
in domain zero okay so it's asynchronous
checkpoint
compression okay so there may be
overhead for doing that but it's
overhead that's incurred by domain zero
it's not it's not on the critical path
of the protected database system but
domain zero suspend the vir Mission
until it sends out and gets an
acknowledgement for the no no no no it
it it will it will as soon as soon as
the pages are here the the virtual
machine can can continue I see network
uh buffered Network packets are not
released until the checkpoint is sent to
the backup but the virtual the protect
virtual machine can continue
executing okay now coming about this
issue of overhead in our implementation
whenever we could offload work from the
protected VM to Dom zero we consider
that as a win so we're not too worried
about Dom zero spending time
asynchronously compression uh spending
time compressing these pages and sending
them over to the backup because we
assume that there is sufficient CPU
capacity for Dom
zero this optimization does it have
anything to do with the buffer po per se
or could this apply to any application
it's inspired by the buffer pool but
it's applicable to any database uh any
any workload where you have uh
redundancy in the replication
stream the so so in some respects uh
what's the name Remis Remis Remis
running the the um the database is that
unchanged for
Remus um running arbitrary applications
yes yes I mean all the changes occur in
domain zero is that what you're saying
uh in domain zero and there's a little
bit of change in in the vertu monitor
but the database system shouldn't be
changed at all and and and the VM that's
running it isn't changed it's not
changed
okay running too many machine it can it
can this not something we we we studied
in this
one so ahed so the the the assumption
that you have is that to begin with
there is no competition between the two
the two virtual machines which means
that you can count anything that this
one does as a win for that one yes yes
does it hold usually in in systems if
you have a system with sufficient CPU I
mean with if you have enough CPUs you
can dedicate CPU to Dom zero and
assumption
with will you get data from
the virtual machine or vir machine do we
need to do some synching
see some uh you need to get a a
snapshot right of of datab page of
virtual virtual mation do we need to the
main zero
operation doesn't need to synchronize
with yes so so while the snapshot's
being taken this virtual machine is
suspended that's a synchronization we do
and that's when when the check when the
when the data is copied the virtu
machine can be resumed and then the rest
of the checkpointing can happen
asynchronous so how long will it take
to finish
this the the how long is the duration or
the virtu machine is suspended I don't
have the number of stuff my head but
it's a small number of
milliseconds okay so the second
optimization implemented
is again an optimization that's inspired
by the buffer pool so if you look at the
way database systems read data from the
database you have have an active virtual
machine and a standby virtual machine
and both of them have their own discs
and there's a copy of the database on
each
disk now when the a database system
loads a page from disk into its buffer
pool it looks clean to the databased
system but it's dirty to Remis so Remis
will synchronize these dirty buffer pool
pages to the backup with every
checkpoint and this greed tracking says
that is based on the fact that
synchronizing these clean buffer pool
pages is not necessary because you can
always read them the backup can always
read them from its copy of the database
so what we do in this optimization is we
track for any discret again this is not
specific to the buffer pool it's
inspired by the buffer pool but what we
do is for any disre we track the memory
pages into which the read data is copied
the Red Data is copied and we don't Mark
the much dirty we don't send them in
checkpoints what we do is we send an
annotation in the replication stream
telling the backup you should read these
pages from your copy of the data
database and put them in your in in your
memory
uh to reconstruct these pages okay and
the backup can do this read lazily so uh
we only need to do this read from the
dis when a failover happens but in
reality what we do is we read these data
uh periodically so that we can make we
can shorten fill over
time
okay so these are yes
Amed so that particular one cannot be
transparent right that particular
optimization needs needs needs the the
the protected virtual machine to be able
to talk to Rema somehow to tell it to
Mark so the protected virtual machine
doesn't read and Remis figures out that
the the Remis gives the Zen gives the
data back to that virtual machine and at
the same time remas sends over
to the other Remis on the backup virtual
machine uh an annotation saying you
should read these dis pages and put them
in your memory how does it know that
this is a datab DAT it it doesn't care
it's a it's a dis read that was read
from dis and put in some page of memory
and the assum okay
okay so the assumption that even even if
no business is run at all the the the
the the virtual machine has an exact
replica or the same copy of the dat data
not database think the DAT the primary
and the backup are replicas of each
other including the local
disc so are these Pages sent to domain
zero and then domain zero does the
detection or is there something else
going on yes yes that's the way Zen does
reads I mean the the domain zero is
involved in the reads and it detects uh
it does this detection okay so so again
there no it's not necessary for so so
when you're when you're doing a
checkpointing at at the
at the 25 millisecond interval and and
you're suspending the machine briefly
and shipping over the stuff how do you
how in that process do you do you do you
distinguish the pages that have
changed um via a disagree from those
that have changed for updates or don't
you
uh you don't I mean so so remas so the
way remas originally worked was that it
marked all all pages as read only and
the first time the protected virtual
machine modifies a page it raises a an
exception and Remis would detect that oh
this is really this page now needs to be
copied over so what we do with this
optimization is that if a page has been
modified because data is being read into
it from disk we don't Market as read
only we don't uh we basically just send
an annotation that here's a a new page
that's been that's been read and the
backup should read it from its copy of
the disc okay so I think I was
misunderstanding something so so so you
have uh the database in in a virtual
machine and then you got to go through
the checkpoint process but the
checkpoint process doesn't isn't part of
the virtual machine it's it's part of
the system underlying it's it's part of
this keep going back this
drawing
sorry yeah it's part of this here yeah
it's part of the main zero and the
hypervisor benath it
promise never to go back to this
machine so now these two optimization
that I described reduce the overhead of
checkpointing memory and they are
completely transparent to database
system now when you looked at Network we
saw that there is an opportunity for
optimizing uh the way uh remas deals
with network packets and we ended up
with an optimization that's not arent to
database system so if you look at the
way remas handles Network packets remas
buffers every outgoing Network packet
which ensures that clients never see
unsafe execution but it adds up to three
orders of magnitude to the latency of
every Network packet because for Remis
we're assuming that the primary and
backup are in the same network so uh 12
12 and a half millisecs of average
latency is really
high and this is the largest source of
over head for many database workloads
and in particular transactional
workloads and our observation is that
this is unnecessarily conservative for
database systems because database
systems have their own transactions with
clear consistency and durability
semantics so we don't need these uh TCP
level per checkpoint transactions that
Remis adds so what we did was we added
to Remis an interface that allows a
database system or any application to
say that these packets need to be
protected or buffered to the next
checkpoint and these packets don't need
to be protected and though this exposed
application is via a Linux set sock opt
option so you have a socket and there's
a toggle switch with with every socket
that says this socket is not protected
it's unprotected and The way database
system uses this uh uh switch is that it
only protects transaction control
packets begin transaction commit abort
these have to be protected all other
packets are sent
unprotected which means that the client
sees unsafe uh state so if a client sees
unsafe State what happens when the
primary fails a fail over after failover
a a failover Handler runs in the backup
virtual machine in a failover Handler
thread and that failover Handler
recovery Handler or failover Handler
aborts all inflight transactions where
the connection to the client was not in
protected
state so database systems are allowed to
abort transactions so for to get a
significant boost in overhead uh a
significant boost in performance during
normal operation we pay this small cost
of aborting extra transactions on
failover this is not transparent to the
database system we need to toggle this
uh socket between protected unprotected
State and we need to do the abortion
aborting inflight transactions after
failover and we actually implemented
this in both post SQL and MySQL and we
ended up having to mod mod ify maybe 100
lines of code in each
system so let me show you how this works
so this is our experimental setup it's
exactly the picture I was showing we
have a primary server a backup server
connected via uh high-speed Network and
we're running MySQL and post
SQL
yes does this modification include
the the F over Handler that was needed
to yes this 100 lines of code includes
everything
so first of all can we do
failover here I'm showing you tpcc on
MySQL and on the x-axis I'm showing time
on the y axis I'm showing throughput
transactions per minute C and the green
line is an unprotected virtual machine
in our setting we can get uh sustained
throughput of around 400 transactions
per minute if we run unmodified Remis we
get this red line so there's a
significant performance overhead if we
run protected Remis sorry if we run
modified Remis Remis DB we get this blue
line we significantly reduce overhead
now in this experiment halfway through
the experiment we fail the primary
server actually pull the plug on the
primary server and the unprotected
virtual machine can't proceed beyond
that through drops to zero it's not
available anymore both protected virtual
machines proceed with very little
downtime and they actually achieve Peak
Performance they achieve the same
performance as the unpr virtual machine
why does performance jump in this way
because now the Backup backup has taken
over as the primary and it's not
protected
anymore so what we're not advocating
that you failed the your your machine to
get better performance what we what
we're seeing here is that you if you're
not protected you don't pay the cost of
protection so this is fail over now
let's look at overhead during normal
operation
uh so this is tpcc on post SQL and here
if we run unmodified Remis we see this
32% uh uh uh overhead so our performance
is 68 of unmodified uh of an unprotected
virtual
machine if we use Remis DB's transparent
memory optimizations we recover most of
that performance but if we also use the
uh non-transparent commit protection we
get back to almost the same performance
as an unprotected virtual machine we got
back to 97% of the performance of the
unprotected virtual machine now the
picture is a little bit different with
tpch tpch doesn't have this back and
forth between client and server so it
doesn't benefit that much from commit
protection doesn't benefit that much
from from the non-transparent network
optimization but we do get a significant
performance boost using the uh memory
optimizations
so that's Remus DB what we've achieved
is high availability for any database
system with no code changes or with very
little code changes if we use these
non-transparent
optimizations and we have now
automatically and fully transparent uh
automatic and fully transparent fail
over to a warmed up system now the next
steps in this project are uh we're
looking at repr protecting a virtual
machine after it fails so we can
tolerate one failure at a time but we
can once we are in this state where the
virtual machine is is is unprotected we
can quickly go back to a state where it
is
protected and one of the nice things
about Remis is that the backup doesn't
have to do a lot of work in normal
during normal operation it's just
applying checkpoints so one possibility
we can explore is to have one server
serve as the backup for multiple uh
primary clients and finally there are
some administrative questions that arise
when you protect the datb system with DB
for example how much Network bandwidth
do we need between the primary and the
backup and we're looking at answering
some of these questions in our current
work so Dave so so if you're a say a
cloud service provider and you're you're
deploying the system um in in the cloud
you've got a bunch of servers and and
you're you're trying to trying to get as
much out of your system as possible
you're going to end up being very
concerned about the performance of Dom
main
zero and and and so question to be asked
is have you measured what the overhead
is of of of domain zero
and no no I mean in our experiments we
were running on the same physical on on
a physical host we were running one
protected virtual machine and one domain
zero mhm so the overhead that one
protect that one virtual machine places
on domain zero is very low M the
situation would be different if we had
10 virtual machines on the physical
server and that's not something we run
the experiment so it would have been
meaningful for us to measure the CP
utilization for example of Dom zero
because it would have been very
low Phil isain zero single
threaded
uh no it's not it's not
so could it so on a multi-core system it
could potentially be running on two
cores currently
Yes Yes actually that's part of the
configuration so then it will scale up
it's even
even ing Dave's concern I mean even if
it gets heavily loaded I mean over time
you're going to see more cores so that's
cores are cheap yeah so so this is all
predicated on cores are cheap and
plentiful uh but I think some of the
concerns that are raised were raised or
that well if you're running in a cloud
environment you don't want to be wasting
cores like this and if you want I mean
we can't avoid the fact that we are
saving time in the protected Virtual
Machine by doing more work in domain
Z and I'm not necessarily concerned
about that I'm just interested in in in
what what it is that you're paying so so
that I can tell whether I should be
concerned I see we didn't measure that
because we're paying CPU cost in domain
zero and cores are cheap and plentiful
so we're willing to pay CPU cost in
domain zero what about communication
cost so that was very low in our setting
that we did measure and we report that
in the paper and it was uh quite low in
our setting especially with our
optimizations that reduce cor
communication
cost I think um I think added to that
particular problem is is basically the
uh like I said the assumption that there
is no contention and um well if you have
a virtual machine that runs one u u that
has only a machine that runs only one
virtual machine that is dedicated I
might I might as well just give it the
core and use another system that doesn't
waste a core for domain zero um and does
dat replication I usually do it because
I can run multiple systems on it MH and
uh what the question that I had in my
mind was um for one virtual machine yes
you have some some extra uh leverage to
give some time to to do the work in
doain zero but if you do that for five
or six you might actually have to uh
have to be paying a penalty per for each
machine that is in aggregate more than
that if you just left it
alone left it alone unpr
yes not or or did it with some other
technique for which it actually so so
this is what we want to
achieve protection with no code change
in a database system and what you're
saying is that we pay a cost for that
and my answer is yes we do I mean the
cost we pay is that we need to provide
processing capacity in domain
zero now can you do this by doing log
shipping and and the database system yes
you
can one last question for yes so what is
the behavior when the backup actually
fails because when the primary fails the
backup becomes uh primary and it's
unprotected so the per is almost the
same as the the uned one but once the
backup fails primary still has to send
all those checkpoints the primary will
figure out that there's nobody receiving
the checkpoints on the other side so it
will stop sending them okay okay so it
it will behave in the same way as if the
backup at field as if the primary
field so now I want to switch gears a
little bit and talk about another
project which is uh about building a
database service by running database
systems on eventually consistent cloud
storage
so Phil should I do I have to stop at
11:30 or can I go to 11:40 okay so I'll
probably try to stop by 11:40 or
thereabouts and uh you guys are already
using your question time in the middle
of my talk
so uh so probably stop at 11:40 and not
have enough and not have too much time
for
questions so so this work is still uh
hasn't been published and here we are
relying on cloud storage so what is this
cloud storage there's many systems these
days that are developed for the cloud
things like Amazon S3 things like hbas
things like Cassandra and these systems
are all storage systems that are very
scalable distributed fall tolerant but
they provide a very simple interface to
the user they're all key value stores
where the basic operations are right a
row with a specific key or read the row
with a specific
key and they provide atomicity only for
single row operations they don't provide
multi row Atomic transactions and they
don't provide the richness of SQL which
is why they're called No SQL
systems and in this uh work what we're
saying is if we have one of these
scalable cloud storage systems that's
running hopefully in multiple data
centers to provide disaster tolerance
can we build a multi-tenant database
service in this setting by
running independent database systems on
this cloud storage
system so here we're not interested in
scaling an individual database tenant we
assume that one machine has sufficient
CPU has sufficient capacity for one
tenant but we're interested in scaling
the storage capacity and bandwidth
available for each tenant and in scaling
the number of
tenants so we want to build a scalable
elastic highly available multi-tenant
database
service that guarantees that supports
SQL and asset
transactions and the idea is that the
cloud storage system will provide the
scalability elasticity and availability
and these database tenants the the
database systems will provide SQL and
asset
transactions so we implemented a
prototype of a system like this and in
our prototype what we wanted to look at
is
if we are building this service on top
of an eventually consistent storage
system can we take advantage of the
relaxed consistency of the storage
system to give us better uh performance
so our prototype is called debex which
stands for databases on eventually
consistent stores and in our prototype
we use MySQL and it's NB storage engine
actually nothing in what we do is
specific to mySQL so we could have
placed my SQL with any other database
system but the
storage uh system that we uses Cassandra
and we do rely on Cassandra because we
want eventual
consistency so I'll talk more about this
system but viac had a question yeah I
was try to understand multi tency model
go back to the So when you say dbms so
should I interpret that as one datab
server this is one instance of
MySQL with its own clients and its own
databases and it's independent of all
the other instances of my escal running
and those two for example if you take
two dbms instances they're running on
different machines different machines
different
databases but they share the storage sub
they share the storage subsystem but
they each have their
own blocks within the storage
system so basically what we want is to
add more and more tenants not to grow
one
t okay so why
Cassandra as I said Cassandra uses
eventual consistency so by relaxing
consistency it reduces the latency of
Rights and it enables uh and it it's
partition tolerant it can run in
multiple uh data
centers so let me spend a few minutes
talking about Cassandra Cassandra stores
data as semi-structured rows that are
grouped into column families so think of
these column families as tables and
within a table or a column family you
have semi-structured
rows and these rows are accessed by a
key so every row has a key and rows are
replicated and distributed by hashing
these
Keys one of the nice things about
Cassandra is that it uses multimaster
replication for each
row many of these uh cloud storage
systems try to guarantee consistency and
they do that by having a single Master
Cassandra doesn't do that Cassandra has
a multimaster for each row which enables
Cassandra to run in multiple data
centers and gives us partition tolerance
and we'll rely on that for uh disaster
tolerance in our system in
debex another nice thing about Cassandra
is that a client controls the
consistency of each right so there is
this consistency versus latency tradeoff
and Cassandra allows the client to
manage this with every read or right
operation so in Cassandra a read or
right operation specifies the
consistency level and the client can say
write one or read one which means get me
any copy of the data or write one copy
of the data and that's fast but not
necessarily consistent there's also
write all and read all which means read
all the copies of the data and get me
the most recent or write all copies of
the data and that's consistent but maybe
slow so Cassandra allows a client to
control this latency versus consistency
tradeoff and in this work we posit that
database systems can control this
trade-off very well so so um you say
right you illustrate this with write all
read all can I do write all read one yes
you can yes so you can dos yes yes there
is there's actually an explicit read
quum so uh in my next SL I'll talk I'll
talk more about these consistency levels
but now I want to give a broader
overview of Cassandra now another nice
feature in Cassandra is that Cassandra
uses timestamps with each uh uh right
and these time stamps are provided by
the client so the client controls the
serialization order of updates and this
is important for us in our system
Cassandra is also scalable elastic and
highly available but so are many other
storage systems so we didn't choose
Cassandra because it's scalable elastic
available we chose Cassandra because of
this so let's talk a little bit more
about uh this consistency versus latency
trade-off so in Cassandra there is uh an
operation I mean when you specify a read
you specify a consistency level so the
basic operation is to read the value of
a specific column in a row with a
specific key so you give the column name
you give the key and then you specify
consistency level you can say read one
which means that Cassandra will send the
read request to all replicas of this row
and it finds the replicas by hashing on
the key
and it returns a value to the client as
soon as one replica
responds so it's fast but may return
still
data now there's also read all where uh
Cassandra sends the read request to all
replicas of the of the row and it waits
for all of them to respond and Returns
the latest copy so this is consistent
but it's as slow as the slowest replica
there's also right one versus right all
so you uh Cassandra sends the right
request to all replicas and it either
acknowledges as soon as one replica
responds or when all it has to wait for
all replicas to
respond and there's also other
consistency level so there's read Quorum
there's also data center aware
consistency
levels so there's this trade-off now
let's quantify the the P this tradeoff
so consistency is possible but it's
expensive so how expensive so to do that
we ran some experiments and here we're
running Cassandra in uh the E Amazon's
ec2 cloud and we have a system with four
Cassandra nodes so small Cassandra
cluster and we're running this Benchmark
called the Yahoo Cloud serving Benchmark
which is uh a very simple Benchmark that
does reads and writes so no no fancy SQL
here and here I'm showing the latency of
wrs and reads blue is write all uh and
read all is right one and read one and
here all the four cassander nodes are in
the same ec2 availability Zone think of
this is the same data center so you see
that there is a factor of two penalty
between the read one and read all but if
we move two of the E of the Cassandra
nodes to two ec2 availability zones
within the same geographic region the
penalty becomes
bigger and if we move the uh two
cassander nodes to a different
geographic region in two different data
centers one on the US east coast and one
the US West Coast the penalty becomes
huge the difference in performance
between the consistent read and write
and the potentially inconsistent read
and WR becomes very
big so the message from these
experiments is that there is a
significant cost to be paid if we use
read all and write all especially if we
want multi- dat center
operation
all four all so there is no here so so
it doesn't it doesn't do any any any try
to say if two or three agreed that this
is the latest one it all means all of
them all means all how because you have
to wait for everybody to respond to
decide which is the latest one but it
doesn't manage it doesn't manage its own
consistency so that it relies on the
majority being being the majority tells
you you can say read Quorum write Quorum
if you
want but you but still your Quorum here
is is the distributed among two data
centers so you still have to wait for
somebody from the other Center to to
respond okay so this is an overview of
Cassandra so what did we want to do with
Cassandra in this project we want
Cassandra to look like a disc to the
database system so a scalable elastic
highly available transcontinental dis so
what what we're going to store in
Cassandra is dis blocks so Cassandra
data Cassandra stores rows with keys and
values in our case keys are uh disk
block IDs and because we have different
database tenants we append the database
system ID to that values are the
contents of dis
block and we don't do anything fancy
with Cassandra's columns and column
families we just have one column family
with one column containing all our
data and we have this
layer this client library that
intercepts read and write requests from
the database system in our case from
MySQL NB storage engine and it converts
them to read and write requests in
Cassandra and the question here is what
consistency level should the Cassandra
IO layer use if it uses WR one and read
one it's fast but might return still
data and it provides no durability
guarantees and reading stale data makes
database systems very unhappy so this is
not something that will work for a
database system now if we want one way
to get consistency is to use write all
and read one which is what what Dave was
was uh mentioning and that returns no
stale data and guarantees durability but
rights are
slow so our goal in this project is to
try to achieve the performance of right
one and read one while maintaining
consistency durability and
availability and we do that by making
two changes to uh Cassandra and to the
way we use Cassandra the first is
something we call optimistic IO in which
we say well if right one and read one
are cheap let's just use right one and
read one and if we happen to get stale
data let's detect that and recover from
it the second change we made is what's
something we call client controlled
synchronization when we when we when we
use write one and read one we lose
durability client controlled
synchronization gives us back uh
durability it makes database update safe
in the face of
failures so let me spend a few minutes
talking about each of these
optimizations so optimistic
IO a key observation we had here is that
even if we use right one and read one
most of the time reads will not return
stale data
why is that are we just looking at the
world with pink glasses no there is
reason there are reasons for that first
of all we have a single writer for each
database
block we have many different database
blocks that that belong to many
different database tenants but we have a
single writer for each database
block and secondly because these writers
because these clients are database
systems they have a buffer pool so when
a database system writes a block it's
unlikely to immediately turn around and
read the same Block it's going to it's
the the block is in the buffer pool so
it will it will like there's likely
going to be a period of time between the
right and the next read of this
block and in that time even if Cassandra
uses right one the uh update would have
propagated to all replicas because
remember with right one Cassandra sends
the the right to all replicas it just
responds as soon as one of them
acknowledg
it and finally there is a factor that's
not really important but it's it's also
part of the picture which is that
because of network topology the first
client to the first cassander note to
acknowledge a right is likely to be the
same with is likely to be the same not
to acknowledge read so because of all of
these reasons if we use write one and
read one most of the time we will not
see stale data but there is a likelihood
of seeing stale data so what should we
do well what we do is detect stale data
and recover from it so how do we detect
stale data there's this Cassandra IO
layer
in the client and this Cassandra I layer
stores a version number with every block
in Cassandra and it remembers the most
recent version number of every database
block and when we use read
one we check the version number that's
returned by the read one against the
most recent version number if it's the
most recent we're fine our optimism was
warranted if we detect stale data then
we have to recover and retry the read
and when we retry the read read we can
use read all so that we can be
guaranteed to get the most recent copy
and an interesting observation is that
even if we retry the read using read one
we are likely to get the most recent
copy why is that because when cassander
detects stenness it initiates a repair
process whereby it brings all the
replicas up to date so if we retry the
read one we're likely to see that
Cassandra has already repaired this uh
this stale
rope now
remembering the version number of each
block seems expensive do we really
remember the version number of each
block the answer is no what we do is we
remember the version number the most
recent version number of only the most
frequently or most recently uh touched
dis blocks so our cassander I layer
considers a block to be in one of three
states either unknown inconsistent or
consistent unknown means I don't know
the the most recent version number and I
have no information about this block
this is the way all this is this is all
the dis blocks when when all the blocks
when the database first
starts so what do I do if my if I'm
reading a block that's in the unknown
State I use read
all once I read a block I get the most
recent version number if once I do read
all I get the most recent version number
I can store
that okay and if I
write a block and I know the most recent
version number of it then I
then I know that this is this is a block
that might be
inconsistent so I can use read one for
that block but I
compare I have to compare the version
number return from Cassandra with the
most recent version number which I know
of now we've also modified Cassandra so
that whenever it responds with a version
number it gives us not just the newest
version number but also the oldest
version number and as we're interacting
with Cassandra we're Al we're always
comparing the newest and oldest version
numbers of different dis blocks and if
the newest and oldest are the same then
we know that the block is consistent
what does consistent mean it means I can
use read one and I don't even need to
check version
numbers and I maintain a bounded sized
list of consistent blocks a bounded
sized list of inconsistent blocks and if
any of these lists uh outgrows this
bounded size I just return the least
recently used blocks to the inconsistent
state to the unknown State I can always
rely on read all if I don't know about
this block about the state of uh a block
da isn't there something you can
delegate to
Cassandra uh remembering the most so how
how would you how would we delegate
remembering the most recent version
numberand by having it having it I mean
have to change Cassandra to do this but
you could have Cassandra now
alternatively you could you could pass
the version number two Cassandra and say
I'll take I'll take the block which
matches this as soon as you find
it that that's an interesting
possibility we haven't looked into that
so so basically one of the things about
Cassandra is that the client might might
connect to different Cassandra nodes
different times so if you pass the
version number to Cassandra until it
give me the the version number that's
this or higher we can do that but right
now what we're doing is is keeping this
outside
of
because it depends upon which one you
want to change versus which one you
don't want to change yeah yes yes and
also any solution that we' come up with
has to uh work under the assumption that
the client will connect differenter
nodes for different
requests so by maintaining the version
list in our uh client
Library maybe we make this maybe we
avoid having Pro problems that arise
when connect different not different
well Cassandra could use the same
strategy right yeah yeah yeah I I I
guess I guess fundamentally there is no
reason why this has to be in the Cent
Library not
in so now we're we're able to use read
one and write one for most uh of our
requests but we our data is not safe
right ones are not safe and also if I
use read all this will block if any
replica down so how can we deal with
failures one naive solution would be to
say I'm going to use write all and read
Corum and if node is down the right will
block but what we did in our system is
again observe that data because database
systems have their
well-defined transaction
semantics they know precisely when data
must be safe and when data can be
unsafe so for example right ahead
logging tells us that you have to write
a log record before you write the
corresponding Data Page you have to you
have to flush the log tail when you do
commit if you are reclaiming uh records
from the log you have to write the
corresponding data Pages there is a
well- defined uh set of points where
data has to be made safe and database
systems are used to dealing with file
systems that don't always guarantee
safety so they're used to saying F sync
or something like fsync when they want
data to be
safe so if we can add something like
fsync for Cassandra then we can afford
to keep data unsafe until fsync is
called well what happened when what
happens when a failure happens and we
lose unsafe data it's exactly what will
happen if a database system loses unsafe
data you abort uh
transactions okay so what we did was
implemented a new type of writing
Cassandra called WR cync and cync stands
for client controlled synchronization
this is a new consistency level for WR
sync Ascender and right cync behaves
like right one so it acknowledges the
client as soon as one copy of the data
is written but it keeps the key of this
page on an inmemory list called the sync
pending list so these are blocks that
need to be synchronized when the client
issues a right sync and we also added a
new call uh in the Cassandra client
called cync Cassandra sync
and whenever the database system
says fsync the Cassandra iio layer which
is the layer between databas Sy
Cassandra uh translates it fsync into a
cync okay so basically we're making data
safe only when the database system needs
it to be
safe so data that's written remains
unsafe until the database system
explicitly requests for this data to be
safe and any period of time between the
right and the cync is an opportunity for
latency hiding Cassandra can be
propagating the uh data while and the
client doesn't have to be waiting for
it what about reads we use read quorum
to deal with the possibility of one of
uh uh cassander noes being
down
theing that transl to right all into
like for right for all of the the
pending ones right them all no so cync
is something that has to be that needed
extra implementation inside cassander so
basically when we write with this new
cync synchronization level there there's
this every cassander nodes accumulate
accumulates keys on this sync pending
list right and what when we send a cync
call to the cassander node what we're
saying is do a write all for every key
on this sync pending list that's what
I'm saying so inside that particular
inside Cassandra yes it becomes a right
I have these that haven't been flushed
yet that haven't been syn all and there
there's more so
basically we can make this cync instead
of doing right all do right to multiple
data
centers so you don't have to write all
cop so the reum actually can can be
you're trying to say that the it'll be
faster for the next we cor and we don't
have to wait for
all I'm not sure
understand the idea is that instead of
saying write all make sure that you
write at least to two Disaster Recovery
uh zone so that you are protected at
least and you can yes what I'm saying is
we can do these kinds of things when we
implement the seent
call so I thought a right once actually
wrote everything but only but act as
soon as there was a there was a anyone
came back saying that it was yes and so
so if you could track how many came back
you could you could discharge your your
cync list sort of as things go on and
not have to do it other right all right
um
yes there is the opportunity to uh clean
the CN the sync pending list without
waiting for a cync I'm not sure if
actually do that or not in aurr
comption cuz that would that would I
mean that's like that's like um
um can't I'm having a brick par moment
here
go so one of the goals We Set uh uh one
of the goals we we uh wanted to achieve
when we started was to deal with
failures so what are examples of of
failures we can deal with so what
happens when we lose a Cassandra node if
we lose a Cassandra node that's
completely transparent into the database
system it's handled by Cassandra
Cassandra detects when the load when the
node is down and it takes it off the
replication ring and when the node is
back comes back up it catches it up with
all the data in it so that's one
advantage of vising system like
Cassandra what about if we lose the
primary data
center here we don't have a fully uh
good story but we have at least a
partial story so here if we are running
Cassandra in multiple data centers and
we have the data stored multiple data
centers which we can do with our
existing implementation we can restart
the database system in a backup data
center so we don't have an always on
database system but we can restart the
database system in the backup data
center and apply the standard log based
recovery to bring the database up to uh
date we can count on a transactionally
consistent view of the log being there
in the backup data center because of the
way we did uh wrs optimistic iio and
because of C
so let's see how this
works so here I'll show you results of
yes so are you using Cassandra for the
vog also yes yes so so so if you're only
doing the right once you wouldn't
necessarily until you did a sync know
that your vog was at disaster C that's
that is true yes so you could you you're
risking losing some of the end of the
log in this if the database system
doesn't do an F sync so we're risking
losing the end of the log whenever
database system would have been willing
to risk losing the end of the log
whenever database system says I I want
to make this data safe by issuing an
fsync we make the data safe in
consent so three or four experiments and
I'll wrap up uh here we're running tpcc
on MySQL in Cassandra in Amazon ec2 we
have a small Cassandra cluster with six
nodes and I'm showing results for three
situations the first is when I have all
six Cassandra nodes in one ec2
availability Zone and the yellow bar
shows the Baseline which is right all
read
one uh the Blue Bar says shows what we
can achieve with optimistic IO so you
can see that you can get a significant
performance boost with optimistic I/O
but optimistic IO is not safe now if we
bring back safety by uh using cync we
pay a little bit of performance penalty
but this performance penalty is not that
high now the difference between the
yellow bar and the Red Bar becomes
bigger if we if the our six cassander
nodes are divided among two availability
zones in the same geographic region and
it becomes even bigger when we are doing
when we are replicating in two
geographic regions Us East and US West
so
basically one way to look at this work
is that we're enabling you to run my SQL
on Cassandra and get the Red performance
instead of the yellow performance if
you're running in two regions Phil
doesn't the performance of the cync bar
depend on how frequently you do cync yes
this is and so how frequently in this
gra
uh this is not something we measur so we
have we have a a tpcc so we do we do
cync whenever my SQL does
fcn how frequent does my do F sync um it
does fsync whenever it it does fsync
with every commit it does fsync uh every
commit it does f sync whenever it needs
to make the data
safe well that's normally at every
commit isn't it yes yes so definitely at
every commit but I think there's also
other situations so when for example
whenever it's reclaiming a page in the
buffer pool it needs to fing the lock
tail before it reclaim the page in The
Bu I mean there are points where where
data must be made safe and the only way
that NV knows how to make a database
safe is to do
FC you have this worried look on your
face and I'm not sure why you're worried
about
it I'm just surprised because that's
very fre that's very frequent hand
shaking across the
wire um I mean all I mean answer Dave
scenario before I mean basically you're
saying at every at every transaction
commit you're going to make sure that
all of you're going to you're going to
eagerly push all the data out to the
replicant yes I think one thing that may
be useful so I don't know if you
probably don't have it in this how does
this compare against the local dis so
what would be the TPM for the local dis
uh actually we we we measured that and
one of the problems we're seeing now is
that is that there is a significant
overhead compared to local
disc because because
every IO in onto local dis is translated
into multiple
IO so so my guess is some of those
concerns could be alleviated a bit by
noting that if you do group commit which
almost everybody does yes and if it's an
fsync to the log versus an fsync to the
to the database discs you would separate
out those overheads also yes yes so so
basically the way Cassandra I mean as
far as I know the way INB used fsync is
that whenever there is a commit you
fsync the lock and if this if only the
lock if this fsync catches a number of
commits you've avoided some f syncs and
you only fsync the data when you're
doing a hard
checkpoint but I'd have to go back and
and and look actually your question
address the point we didn't really
investigate that much which is how
frequently does NB do F Sy but it only
acknowledges a commit to the client
after an fyn yes right I think May do it
right the you you will propagate all the
right to all the noes that's the cync
just to ins that this has been done
right the cync propagates all the rights
the right to all the nodes yes but
that's only done when the database
system request yes uh when you uh issue
a uh a red syn a red C sync mean that
this thre will be provocated to the
other no right at the time so the C syn
just Ur that at the point you're
tracking all this s has been updated has
been synchronized so that's maybe the
reason why you frequently uh call the uh
seasoning still the performance is not
because the thing is going on all time
plus when you call the seasoning you
check whether the sing has well but
that's not what he said last time he
said he wasn't sure whether the code was
actually checking to see whether the
stuff was done and was actually pushing
it think you right all the rights beated
to all imagine imagine the
implementation underneath it it it might
might be that the actual implementation
didn't make sure that to to flush the
syn list but the right all request would
from the Cassandra layer would return I
would assume much faster if the Sync has
already been
happening one with
home so let me move on I want to show
you so basically the message of this
graph is you get to use my SQL on top of
Cassandra with the Red performance
instead of the Yow performance now let's
look at the goals we set out to achieve
which are scalability and availability
so do we get scalability so here we have
a uh we're adding more and more database
uh tenants they're all running tpcc
they're independent database systems
running independent copies of tbcc and
we're proportionately increasing the
number of Cassandra noes so we start
with uh we have uh two tenants on one
database system and three cassander
nodes then we go to six tenants on nine
Cassandra nodes and so on WE
proportionately increase the number of
tenants and the number of Cassandra
nodes and what we get is a linear scale
up in the total uh tpmc that we see
across all of these tenants so we can
scale in the number of tenants now let's
look at some availability results here
we're running our uh tpcc our
MySQL uh in a data center that we call
the primary data center and then there
are three cassander nodes in this Prim
Center and three cassander nodes in a
secondary data center and we fail one
cassander node in the primary Center at
300 seconds and when we do that there is
a drop in performance until the other
cassander nodes realize that this node
has failed and stop sending requests to
it and then we recover our performance
now this node comes this cassander no
comes back up at 900 seconds and it
takes a while to catch up this node with
other Cassandra nodes so performance
gradually Rises until we get to the
original performance
yes so you you say that you so for every
tenant you add one
node uh no no it's I mean we we we saw
how in our setting how much uh capacity
we we
can how much load can a node sustain and
it turns out that for
um every one of the virtual machines we
are using can sustain two my two instan
of myql and these two in of my SQL need
three cender noes
state so but but that is not so so what
you're saying is that I add scalability
by adding more nodes that
is that that that's that's definition of
scalability there there's no magic you
if your system is overloaded you only so
what I can tell you is that every one of
these points represents a highly loaded
system so here it's a high loaded system
with a number of with some number of
nodes and here it's a high loaded system
with many more nod so the idea is that
this is not it's not doing like this
it's basically it's the idea is that
this is linear linear scale it's not
doing like
this oh sorry yes so
so you can you can imagine running TVC
in a couple of different ways one is
each of your each of your of your
systems runs the TPC Benchmark and so
every time you add a you're running
adding another one ref runs the TPC Ben
yes is that what you did yes
so so what you do what so that's if you
will perfectly partitionable because
those are all partitions yes so was
you're not showing the scalability where
you just sort of stretch out the size of
the of the cluster machines that's
running a single instance of
tpcc uh so this so so your scalability
is like we we add independent clients
doing independent things inv thisable to
get right yes so basically the the
storage system is able to support more
and more independent clients yes
absolutely so availability I showed you
what happens when a Cassandra node in
the primary data center fails this is
what happens when a cassander node in
the secondary data center fails you
don't see as much of a performance hit
because the secondary the no in the
secondary Center is not on the critical
path most of the time
now here's what happens when we
completely lose the primary data center
and here the story is not as nice it's
still okay so what happens is that you
have some performance and then at 300
seconds we completely fail the primary
data center now what happens is
that we start a new database instance in
the secondary data center and this
instance does traditional log based
recovery it find the log is there in
Cassandra it's transactionally
consistent after it's done with its
recovery it
uh comes back up and starts executing
queries and the reason why the
performance after recovery is lower than
the performance before recovery is that
here it's US Coast East here it's US
Coast West and East is closer to waterl
than West or actually East is closer to
the primary uh uh uh the database
instance than
West I don't understand why you need to
do a database recovering the database is
it's part of your data center yes so we
lost the database data center with
Cassandra and with the database
system so if you have a standby database
that is actually running you can reduce
that time we can but we don't right now
we don't have standby database systems
and standby database systems would open
up an interest a whole bunch of
interesting uh issues if you want to do
standby replication completely ignoring
the the fact that you have a shared
storage then you can do that without any
problems but what would be interesting
is to see if we can exploit the fact
that you have shared storage to make the
standby
faster so what do we have so far we have
scalability and elasticity in storage
capacity and storage bandwidth we have
scalability in the number of tenants and
we have a highly available and disaster
tolerant storage tier we have SQL and
asset transactions for the ten so
there's this question about whether we
can scale consistency can consistently
scale and what we have now is in my view
an interesting point in the spectrum of
possible answers to this question now
what is it that we don't have we don't
have what Dave was talking about scaling
an individual database system that's not
something we have looked at yet and we
don't have always on tenants so when our
tenant fails we have the advantage that
when we restart the tenant in another
data center that new started tenant can
find a copy of database in the log and
do log based recovery but we still have
to incur downtown we don't have this uh
automatic and transparent
failover so let me conclude and I can
take any other questions offline so in
this
talk what I argued was that high
availability and also scalability for
database systems can be provided by the
cloud infrastructure and this is not
something that's new many people are
working on different projects that aim
achieve this goal but what I tried to uh
look at in this talk is to say that if
we take advantage of the well-known
characteristics and semantics of
database systems we can greatly improve
uh our Solutions and I presented two
examples of this one is Remus DB which
is high availability in the
virtualization layer and the other is
debex which is scalability and high Ava
by running on eventually consistent
Cloud store thank you and sorry for
running
overtime